and you're doing your own stunts for the
most part yeah
and so is ace what's his name alexander
ludwig alexander ludwig now i noticed he
did this big backflip
off the ropes
is he is was he a stuntman is he an
athlete was he a wrestler like would it
no yeah i'll tell you what he is
he's
i think still in his 20s and 2 inches
taller than me and 25 pounds heavier
than i am so thanks so much to stars and
lionsgate
for [ __ ] casting my younger brother
as this guy
uh he is a fellow canadian grew up in
vancouver
and love freestyle skiing
and all that's
just all like he knows how to do
backflips and [ __ ] like that and he's
like hey should do a backflip it's it's
arrogant it's uh you know perfunctory
like it doesn't matter that's what he
should do and you just climb up the top
rope and just do it and stick it every
time
were they worried about you guys getting
hurt or because you i know you probably
are just like i want to do this let me
do this let me do this and they're
constantly like [ __ ] is this is this a
question or do you know what happened
the first day that we shot wrestling no
tell me oh my god
so
when the show opens you see me type in
coast to coast and you see me do a
coast-to-coast
which is
you get up on the ropes on one side you
jump to the other side of the ring
right and you kind of like smash it down
smash guy hit him with your feet right
right
and so anyway we did the first take i i
nailed it i didn't i didn't jump as far
as i wanted to and i didn't realize they
were going to cut to another camera that
was going to be behind the guy that it
was kicking so you know depth of field
you can't tell that i came up short
but i watched it back on the monitors
and i was like well
nailed that
you guys are all set up
we're lit let's just do it again
and the idea of doing it again was i
want to get as high and jump as far
as i possibly can
and i did
and i wasn't able to
extend my body so instead i landed
basically sitting straight up
with my legs perpendicular to my torso
compression fracture t10 and l1
vertebrae
day one day one day one of wrestling
and the studio's probably livid oh my
god they're flipping out they're not
they're not livid but they're like
really
actually
because you hear a broken back
and for the first 24 hours
i didn't think that i'd be back to work
for months because every muscle
around that area stiffens up stiffens up
oh [ __ ]
they took me
just because i i know you appreciate
this with back stuff and that stuff they
took me to the hospital now once the
muscles released
released
i was i felt fine
and i was back to work in like three
four days not doing stunts until a a
little bit later but
it's healed i'm all good i was very very
lucky
um
but
oh goodness i forgot i was going to say
about you you got injured and you
thought you're going to be gone for
months and then you come back and then
yeah everything will get oh okay so i go
to the hospital
and i'm in incredible amounts of pain my
wife is there
and they're like
uh
scale with a 10 what we don't know
what's wrong yet i haven't been x-rayed
scale 1-10 how about your pain and i go
because i couldn't get a full breath
it's a nine and a half
nine yeah i go to nine and a half out of
ten i go i'm an extraordinary amount of
pain to the point that it's making me
introspective like i i'm in i'm in such
pain that i am outside my body right now
thinking about how hopefully
got and the doctor goes looks at
cassandra and says
is what's his pain threshold like and
she goes it's very high he goes okay
morphine
zofran because i was nauseous and valium
pumped
into my arm
and within five minutes cass goes how
are you and i go
is there a chick-fil-a close by
and one of the nurses says